you were the first action sports star to
come out publicly
yeah and that took a lot of guts in it
was something that was weighing on you
for a long time is that right that's
right yeah I I mean I I've always been
gay I knew I was gay I think when I was
like 5 years old I've known for a long
long time but I grew up in a really
small town 2,000 people a class of 48
kids I turned pro as an athlete when I
was 16 and it was just something that
was just like hard for me to kind of
come to terms with and I didn't want to
say anything that I thought was gonna
give me any sort of separation from the
pack I didn't want to differentiate
myself right I don't know alienate
myself anyway so I had a hard time with
that and yeah only really you used to
you worried it was a constant worry that
you might say something in an interview
inadvertently that would let your secret
out is that right and then you finally
decided there was a period
[Laughter]
- but you you were considered for a
while at Sochi coming out maybe on live
television at the Olympics yeah what
were you thinking what were you
contemplating well leading into the
Russian Olympics there was all this anti
LGBT legislature and they had warned
people about like if you're gay or if
you any of the athletes are gay like try
not to show it kind of because this is
not because everyone say yeah it's not
accepted and I was like that's [ __ ]
I'm not gonna I mean I wasn't even now
but I was like that's ridiculous and I
had a boyfriend at the time and had kind
of talked about like landing the best
run ever and like winning an Olympic
gold medal and like kissing him at the
bottom and I was like that'd be my way
of telling everyone but it didn't happen
I'm glad it didn't actually because I
hadn't told my mom my dad my brothers it
was like not only been a shock to the
sport into the Olympics but like my
family
[Laughter]
I was like I'm gonna just take a little
bit and I write after the Olympics I
kind of started telling some of my
friends in my family and then yeah
that's this last summer kind of got my
ducks in a row to come out with the SPN
mm-hmm has it do I mean the relief must
be massive it has been so massive and I
was nervous because I didn't know how
the other skiers and how people were
gonna react to it just because no one's
action sports has done this and so I was
really nervous but everyone for the most
part has been so great that it's it's
been it just makes me feel good
everyone's been amazing Wow
[Applause]